netflix netflix because of
because of quarantine this show ended up
being much more popular than we
anticipated um it when our show aired it
was april 17th
2020 which was like the heart of don't
go outside right
so anybody who even it was like tiger
king and then when i'm done with tiger
king
two out to handle and like that was it i
disagree i think that
it would have been success regardless
you think so yeah yeah yeah i love that
show
did you okay well i think it's better
than the bachelor i agree with that
i think it's a it's very it's a smarter
show for sure it looks better
um i think that regardless i'm making
excuses for myself
i don't think that i would have been
nearly as popular why are you sweating
let's give me the lighting am i sweating
do the makeup girls in here we don't
have makeup girl
girls we got makeup girls we gotta get
some of those huh
jim how proud are you i was asking you
before now i can hear him now i can hear
him talk to him
okay yeah go closer to the mic yeah you
know i'm real proud of him you know he
he he keeps he keeps himself you know uh
above board you know he doesn't do
anything no i don't we're not saying he
does anything i think he's doing what a
single good-looking person should do
i told him i said don't do anything i
wouldn't do right oh my god
you sir jim are a [ __ ] that's
we got to the bottom of it don't do
anything i wouldn't do and he's now
making out with strange women
in front of 190 countries when's the
last time you did that jim oh my gosh
there you go oh my gosh
is that her that's chloe that's chloe
yeah what is on chloe's thigh
is that a tattoo i think that's me oh
no it is a tattoo what does chloe's
inner thigh tattoo say i forget it
i forget i didn't stare that long
but uh i did i did know at one point in
time it has been a couple years since
i've seen her you you read her inner
thigh and you forgot what it said uh
yeah
it's too close to other things i was
more paying attention to
what were you paying attention no i
don't know her dress is really nice
there
yeah her mouth was nice as well i was
also kind of drunk in this scene
i um the uh the producers gave us two
drinks a night oh wait wait a second so
you're drunk in the scene and she's
making out with you do you feel like you
were taking advantage of
no no so so i gotta be careful with that
now
no so the uh i we're only allowed two
drinks
per night i like to drink it's a bit of
my
but that two long island iced teas could
be sure but they weren't
they were very weak drinks and because
for whatever reason maybe they didn't
want us to break the rules or what but
they didn't want us
to get drunk um everyone else they
weren't
much drink much of drinkers anyway so i
would kind of finish everyone else's
drinks when i was
on set one second my son keeps wandering
in and looking am i crossing a line alex
am i
every my kids seem to be worried about
what i'm going too long am i going too
long no no no
i'm just i'm just looking at what was on
the screen every time you're looking at
the ladies yeah
so afterwards you're going to say you
were trying to read her inner thigh
weren't challenged i was just i was
shopping
i was shopping shopping shopping oh my
god that's not good
no so these are people oh no no i'm not
not oh yeah
yeah okay so uh so that scene
um i i i had a couple more drinks than i
usually did
how did you get more drinks if they're
if they're only giving you two because a
bunch of people had other scenes that
they were filming
around the thing around the villa so
they would leave their cocktails kind of
on the on the side and i knew this scene
was coming up where i was gonna kiss
chloe there was a written in scene we
it was a planned rule so let me just as
a germaphobe yeah number one
you don't know chloe and you were gonna
kiss her and the way to kiss her is to
drink out of other people's cups well to
be fair i poured it into my own cup
and alcohol i figured in my brain
alcohol kills all the germs
so you're missing it the most
interesting part to me maybe just
because i'm so into these reality
reality shows is that that part was
scripted you guys knew that you were
going to kiss each other
they told you that it ahead of time yeah
so who tells you that it's not the
producers
said i want you to make out with this
thing he said we're gonna guys we gotta
start breaking some rules
so so when you guys lost
money it wasn't really your fault for
losing money did they tell you i would
say about half of them
were um we lost much much much more
money
than you was actually shown on the show
but we also gained it all back doing
various little tasks did you get paid
for the show
no but i was a winner on the show so we
split the remaining pot which was
75 000 so i made 2 500 on the show
which was the grand prize but the value
to your instagram accounts and your life
is right
it's it's invaluable the the stuff that
have cut
the stuff that's has come from doing
this
um be it just instagram you know
influencing or traveling around the
world and getting things
comped or dinners or or even an
opportunity to be on this podcast
honestly i would never probably alex
lynn to my dm's i'm gonna put him on
blast did you know that
yeah alex alex francesca
nicole and alex and alex
that's what it is exactly my son is one
out of three right exactly
so but alex i like at least as much as
everyone else
are you on the new season i am on the
new season yeah sorry i had a question
yeah you can go on with that i just
thought it was really interesting too
that you said it's only two drinks i've
seen yeah
on other reality shows or you've heard
that they like
feed right because you want you to be
sloppy and drunk and angry and fight
so if the key is that you're not allowed
to touch people
right what are some strategies do you
masturbate you're not allowed
not allowed to masturbate either you're
backed up for i was backed up wait a
minute you're not how do they know that
you're not master
camera's everywhere every single place
there isn't one place you can go like in
the shower
shower there's cameras and if you say if
you take a shower for longer than like
three minutes the camera goes
making sure you're like you're really
not doing anything right so the camera's
up
you got to get it done with all these
people two minutes well check this out
and soap and in the back of your mind
you don't want to be the guy who loses
money from
whacking it right if you're going to
lose money at least
women will look at you as a real
strategist oh yeah you know what that
happened in the second season some guy
asked for permission to masturbate for
strategy
we would have been found out murdered by
the rest of my cast if i did something
like that
absolutely not
[Music]